il y a une chose que je ne pourrai
jamais c'est d'écrire dans aspect de la
France et River
je ressemble à Verlaine
[Musique]
je ressemble à Verlaine à cause de la
barbe et toi tu ressembles à Rimbaud
parce que tu es ravissante est-il vrai
que tu as commencé à voir quand tu étais
prof pour ne pas bégayer et c'est la
vérité car je bégayais
abominablement bien
j'ai été professeur de philosophie j'ai
eu 30 élèves il y en a 29 qui ont été
reçus
après j'ai fait deux ans en Allemagne
et en me disant la philosophie c'est
géniale mais pourquoi est-ce que 29
gains ont été reçus et ben ils ont été
reçus parce que sans perdre un an c'est
comme si il redoublait car je leur
répétais deux fois ce que j'avais à
l'ordi et oui par le bégaiement
exactement à une de plus beaux aphories
c'est on voit ensemble mais on est sous
tout seul explication
et bien on n'est pas sous avec quelqu'un
on est sous avec soi-même
et bien moi
quant à moi je dirais
quand je vois je ne suis pas seul en
France ce que je vois double il y a
Gainsbourg
ah c'est pas bête et s'il y a une glace
tu es 4
comme moi dans une glace je me vois 4
et ce n'est pas fini ce soir je serai 8
de notre phrase de ce jeune homme
fringant je ne me regroupe pas
avec une seringue
avec une seringue non mais avec une
double seringue dans un monde d'hiver ça
va tout seul on peut mettre aussi le
blocage
oui c'est trop enfin si on veut pas
faire autrement s'il vous plaît pour
nous deux
j'ai 8 dit que quand tu écris tu arrêtes
de boire mais au wagon c'est la vérité
mais
j'écris de moins en moins ah oui
ça me trompe moins
on a un point comme un Twitter on aime
les flics et commissaires je suis allé
33 fois au commissariat de police donc
33 mètres avec les pinces toujours avec
les pinces qu'il retire pour que je
puisse me moucher ou faire autre chose
mais exactement couler un bon soi-même
mais se faire couler par quelqu'un
d'autre c'est tout drôle aussi dégueu
on a un point commun
une chose que je ne ferai jamais c'est
d'écrire dans aspect de la France et
Riverdale je l'ai fait mais j'ai écrit
dans l'humanité aussi ah oui
la droite me croit de gauche jouer entre
les deux moi je porte à gauche mais plus
bas
un vrai canon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu